Montessori Education is based on the principles developed by Maria Montessori,
who opened her first school for children of low-income workers in an apartment building in Rome in 1907.
The school was called
“Casa dei Bambini”, Home for Children.
This first “Casa” was furnished with a teachers table,
a stove, a blackboard, some chairs,
group tables for the children
and a cabinet filled with materials
that Montessori developed in her earlier career
when she researched how to teach kids who experience some form of mental disability.
Maria Montessori created the materials
after she realised
that students seem to understand complex concepts better when they engaged all their senses.
Activities at this first school included personal care (such as dressing and undressing),
care of the environment like sweeping,
dusting and gardening.
Otherwise they were free to move around
and play with the materials.
Montessori did not teach herself
but instead oversaw the classroom work
of her teachers.
Montessori observed that children showed
episodes of deep concentration
and multiple repetitions of the same activity.
Given free choice,
kids showed more interest in practical activities
and the materials
than normal toys, sweets or other rewards.
Over time spontaneous self-discipline emerged.
Montessori concluded that working independently
children seemed to reach new levels of autonomy and become self-motivated learners.
She began to see the role of the teacher as a facilitator of young human beings
who are free to move and act within the limits of a prepared environment.
The goal: to grow children to become independent and responsible adults who share a love for learning.
Soon after Montessori herself and her ideas
started travelling the world
to inspired progressive thinkers and educators
from all over.
The inventors, Alexander Graham Bell and Thomas Edison, became early advocates.
Later alumni include Jimmy Wales from Wikipedia,
author Gabriel Garcia Marquez
as well as the two Google founders Larry Page and Sergey Brin.
Today the term “Montessori” stands more for a method, than a school itself.
The fact that it can be used freely by anyone led to a great variation of schools.
Educators all over the world borrow Montessori's name,
insights and materials to organize kindergartens,
elementary schools, special needs programs,
or even full 12 year curriculums.
Some parents use it for homeschooling.
The following characteristics are shared
among most programs:
- Students are free to choose what to learn
- Open classrooms that allow free movement
- Use of specialised Montessori materials
- Mixed age classes (from 0-3, 3-6 or 6-12)
so children can learn from each other
- Uninterrupted blocks of study time, usually three hours
- No grading or homework
- and a trained teacher
Maria Montessori once famously said:
“Never help a child with a task
at which he feels he can succeed.”
What are your thoughts on Montessori?
Please share your opinions in the comments below!